I'm in Gibraltar a bit of British
territory on the south coast of Europe
over there is Spain and over there
visible on the horizon is the north
coast of Africa in the 1920s a german
architect named herman zorga saw an
opportunity right here he came up with a
plan to drain the Mediterranean Sea it
didn't seem entirely impossible the
Mediterranean naturally evaporates more
water comes in from the Atlantic then
flows out so if you actually managed to
put a dam across the Straits of
Gibraltar the sea would slowly start to
dry up Zobel said that after the sea
level had dropped maybe 100 200 meters
and a fifth of the water area had turned
to land Europe and Africa will be united
into one continent and there be huge
amounts of new land for settlement and
agriculture and you could use the dam as
a massive hydropower station on a on a
scale never considered before letting
just enough water through to meet the
energy needs of all of his new continent
circle made his plan public in the years
after the First World War perhaps he
thought all that new land an exploration
might be the solution to making sure
that there wasn't a second the project
was called Atlanta Ripper and it is one
of the most ambitious plans that has
ever been announced it would have taken
effort on the scale of the Apollo moon
shot and it certainly got attention from
the press and the public but there were
a few slight problems with it first
there might not have been enough
concrete in the world to build a dam
that big let alone all the other
secondary dams and earthworks elsewhere
needs to make the project work and
Zirkle didn't want to build the dam here
where the Strait of Gibraltar is
narrowest no he wanted to build it about
30 kilometers that way making it much
much longer it would have needed to be
300 meters high and the foundations will
be two and a half kilometers wide but
those are practicalities right humanity
could probably overcome that with enough
effort and enough political will not
that there would have been enough
political will the people on the
Mediterranean coast would be let's say
rather disappointed that they now lived
in land perhaps hundreds of miles from
the sea Venice and Genoa their folks
there were particularly unhappy with
that the plan was popular in his native
Germany but not particularly outside and
as for Africa well the early 20th
century their opinion
didn't matter it wasn't so much emerging
of Europe and Africa as an attempt at
assimilation but let's assume that
somehow over decades the Atlanta project
was built there would have been some
other problems all that a new land would
be salt flats completely unusable for
growing crops Orban well anything really
and all those ogle couldn't have known
it at the time some meteorologists now
reckon that the project might have
diverted the Gulfstream sending
temperatures plunging in most of Europe
and ending local agriculture as we know
it and also when virgle first came up
with his grand plan there likely wasn't
a bomb in the world large enough to
destroy a dam that big certainly not one
go he could you could just about make it
work but that changed quite quickly
during the Second World War having a
single point of failure for millions of
people's homes and lives is not ideal
Zobel died in 1952 and any hope of the
project died with him after we'd spent a
lifetime promoting it but his idea lives
on in science fiction and as a testament
perhaps not to how big we can actually
build but how big we can dream